bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct une heure en compagnie ce soir de
l'écrivain Philippe Besson on est ravi
que vous soyez notre grand témoin ce
soir on va parler de votre dernier livre
chez Julia art ceci n'est pas un fait
divers c'est la chronique bouleversante
glaçante et bien d'un féminicide vu à
travers les yeux du jeune fils de la
victime il y a un livre mais il y a
aussi un film en salle depuis 10 jours
arrête avec tes mensonges c'est un
succès c'est l'adaptation de votre
best-seller qui raconte peut-être le
roman le plus le plus intime votre
homosexualité dans les années 80 on va
parler de tout ça dans la deuxième
partie mais on va commencer ce soir avec
l'actualité à l'Assemblée nationale
après les retraites l'atome le projet de
loi sur le nucléaire étant débat à
partir de ce soir en commission plus de
réacteurs et construit beaucoup plus
vite évidemment le nucléaire est de
retour en graphe mais à quel prix qui va
payer qui va financer les milliards
d'investissements nécessaires on en
parle dans un ant dans notre grand débat
avant de retrouver aux alentours de
20h15 les parties pris de nos affranchis
et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire de jour à l'Assemblée vous me
suivez Philippe Besson je suis et bien
c'est parti
[Musique]
et qu'il est loin le temps où l'on
fermait Fessenheim quel changement de
ton presque toutes les forces politiques
ne jurent plus aujourd'hui que par
l'atome alors évidemment la guerre en
Ukraine et la crise climatique sont
passées par là et c'est dans ce contexte
car il va l'assembler ce soir le projet
de loi sur le nucléaire bonsoir Maud
brégent bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes la rapporteur de ce projet de loi à
l'Assemblée député renaissance des
Hauts-de-Seine porte-parole du groupe
majoritaire vous connaissez bien la
filière du nucléaire parce que vous êtes
une ancienne ingénieur à EDF bonsoir
Julie larnos bonsoir je prononce bien
votre nom très bien parfait vous êtes
député Europe Écologie les vers de
Loire-Atlantique une des dernières
forces politiques j'ai envie de dire à
lutter contre le nucléaire on verra si
bien sûr on verra vous êtes si isolés
que ça ou pas bonsoir Pierre Cordier
ravi de vous accueillir députés à
parenter les républicains des Ardennes
vous avez une centrale nucléaire je
crois dans votre circonscription vous
êtes les membres de la commission
d'enquête qui est très politique sur je
cite les raisons de la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétiques de la France on en parlera
enfin bonsoir Marie-Noëlle baptistel
bienvenue vous êtes députés socialiste
de l'Isère les socialistes sont assez
divisés sur ce texte vous nous direz
pourquoi c'est un débat très politique
ce soir mais on a envie d'entendre le
citoyen vous êtes Philippe Besson donc
n'hésitez surtout pas ça ne doit pas
vous effrayer non non ça va on entendra
des choses à dire tout à l'heure mais
n'hésitez pas à intervenir on va
commencer comme chaque soir par le biais
de Stéphane blackovski pour nous planter
le décor de 100 secondes pourquoi
pourquoi le nucléaire a de nouveau la
cote c'est le chrono de la côte tout de
suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir
à toutes bonsoir à tous donc le
nucléaire revient en force alors je ne
sais pas si vous avez écouté France Info
ce matin il y avait Agnès panier runaché
comme invité et elle rappelait qu'il
faut en moyenne 15 ans pour concevoir et
construire une centrale nucléaire donc
15 ans c'est long merci c'est surtout
très long par rapport au temps politique
parce que ça fait trois quinquennat donc
ça pose la question de savoir si en
France on est capable pendant trois
quinquennat d'avoir un minimum de
Constance sur un sujet aussi important
que le nucléaire alors c'est pas évident
parce que même quand le président reste
plus de 5 ans au pouvoir il peut y avoir
un manque de constance alors vous me
voyez peut-être arriver avec mes gros
sabots parce que le président lui a
annoncé l'an dernier vous en souvenez
son projet de construire 14 nouveaux
réacteurs à l'horizon 2050 sauf que en
2018 c'est-à-dire 4 ans moi cette
annonce ben c'était tout le contraire on
écoute
concrètement 14 réacteurs de 900 MW
seront arrêtés d'ici à 2035
ce mouvement commencera à l'été 2020
avec l'arrêt définitif des deux
réacteurs de Fessenheim
restera alors à organiser la fermeture
de 12 réacteurs entre 2025 et 2035 alors
évidemment quand on est chroniqueur quel
plaisir de faire le malin en pointant
les revirements du président bon comme
disait l'autre que celui qui n'a jamais
changé d'avisette la première pierre
parce que Macron n'est pas le seul à
avoir changé d'avis sur la question du
nucléaire la majorité des Français a
fait exactement pareil regardez
l'évolution de l'opinion alors tantôt il
y a une majorité favorable tantôt une
majorité défavorable ça ne cesse de se
croiser la courbe au fil des années donc
si on revient 15 ans en arrière pour
produire des preuves de 15 ans on est en
2008 là les Français ont confiance dans
le nucléaire d'ailleurs à l'époque il
marchait plutôt bien donc fait une
raison aussi d'avoir confiance mais 2011
d'un seul coup grosse chute de confiance
bien sûr c'est les catastrophes de
Fukushima on peut prendre un exemple je
sais pas si vous savez moi aujourd'hui
Marine Le Pen voudrait construire 20
réacteurs
nouveau et bien en 2011 c'était pas
exactement la même chose c'était même
exactement le contraire le nucléaire est
un une énergie extrêmement dangereuse
nous disons depuis très longtemps
puisqu'il y a des premiers colloques du
Front national en 1979 était justement
sur les dangers du nucléaire il faut
aller vers une sorte du nucléaire si je
vous ai bien entendu je crois que c'est
un objectif oui qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit oui oui parce que parce
qu'encore une fois c'est une énergie qui
est extrêmement dangereuse vous voyez
comme quoi il faut pas jeter la pierre
tout le monde peut changer d'avis sur le
nucléaire moi en revenir à notre cour V
on fait beaucoup de reproches à François
Hollande on lui dit mais aussi François
Hollande qu'est-ce qui lui a pris de
promettre de réduire à 50% le nucléaire
l'objectif 2025 on constate que pendant
la période de son quinquennat en fait il
y avait une large majorité de Français
qui était plutôt aussi le nucléaire donc
il était donc c'est des reproche alors
qu'à l'époque on le soutenait le gros
revirement c'est 2018 le moment on
décide de fermer les centrales et d'un
seul coup bah voilà crise énergétique
prise de conscience climatique alors si
on ajoute la guerre en Ukraine regardez
où on en est aujourd'hui on entend
souvent du coup je veux dire bon il
faudrait supprimer la réforme des
retraites puisque 65% des Français sont
opposés bon bah dans ce cas il faut
relancer le nucléaire puisque 65 % des
Français ils sont favorables même les
électeurs de Yannick Jadot vous voyez il
y a une majorité d'entre eux qui disent
ben la question c'est est-ce que ça de
l'avenir oui ça vaut le coup de miser
malgré tout un peu sur le nucléaire donc
à gauche il y a une grosse désunions
comment peut-on gouverner ensemble quand
on est pas d'accord sur un sujet comme
ça je sais pas mais en tout cas il se
trouve que ça m'énerve ou c'est lui il
est plus proche de Manuel Macron que de
Sandrine Rousseau sur la nucléaire en
tout cas on écoute parce que avoir une
électricité décarbonée c'est se donner
la chance d'avoir une neutralité carbone
en 2050 et de se passer des énergies
fossiles du gouvernement qui parle
devant nous là
je suis pour qu'il y ait un arc
républicain le plus large possible
autour de cette reconquête de notre
souveraineté énergétique bon alors je
vais vous laisser débattre il y a des
pour il y a des contre le nucléaires je
sais pas qui aura raison à la fin mais
ce qui compte c'est qu'une fois on a
pris la décision on s'y tient un peu de
merci beaucoup ce Stéphane il était très
bon le billet de Blacko ce soir alors on
va rentrer dans le détail du projet de
loi dans un second temps si vous voulez
bien mais je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
quand même sur ce moment nucléaire mode
Braison est-ce que pour vous ce qu'on
est en train de traverser en tout cas on
entre dans un moment nucléaire c'est
très bien démontré par Stéphane est-ce
que c'est forcément une bonne nouvelle
c'est un projet de loi qui est pour moi
la concrétisation du discours de Belfort
tenu par le Président de la République
c'était le 20 février 2022 et en fait
c'est la résultante d'une triple
ambition d'abord une ambition écologique
parce que si on veut atteindre la
neutralité carbone on a besoin de
l'ensemble des moyens de production des
carbonée le nucléaire l'hydraulique les
renouvelables c'est aussi une ambition
industrielle Fabien Roussel parler à
juste titre de souveraineté et on a vu
notamment avec la guerre en Ukraine
combien il était important de produire
ses biens de première nécessité chez
nous et l'électricité en fait partie on
avait aussi avec la guerre en Ukraine
pardonnez-moi de vous interrompre que
certaines centrales nucléaires pouvaient
être exposées à porridja en Ukraine
en France et une troisième ambition qui
est une ambition politique aujourd'hui
si on veut relancer une filière remettre
des compétences donner envie aux jeunes
de faire des études de se tourner vers
ces secteurs là on a aussi on a besoin
de porter ce message et donc c'est ce
qu'on fera dans les jours à venir au
sein de la commission et dans deux
semaines au sein de l'émission on va
rentrer dans le détail dans un instant
Julie larnus les écologistes sont
clairement anti-nucléaires on peut le
dire comme ça anti-nucléaire goûter nous
on regarde les faits on n'est pas né
anti-nucléaire c'est qu'on a regardé la
réalité des choses est-ce que le
nucléaire est une solution pour sauver
le climat la réponse est clairement non
pourquoi vous le dites vous-même pour
construire un nouveau réacteur il faut
15 à 20 ans
pour gagner la bataille contre le climat
on a jusqu'à 2025 2030 pour infléchir la
courbe des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc non le nucléaire ne va pas
remplacer les énergies fossiles et donc
pas diminuer nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et donc ne servira pas à
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique il y a un contexte
aujourd'hui ça vaut le reconnaissez il y
a une crise énergétique massive regardez
les Allemands vous avez vu qu'il devait
fermer les dernières centrales
nucléaires ils sont dans la coalition au
pouvoir les écologistes et ils ont
renoncé ça vous fait pas réfléchir les
Allemands va trouver plus antinucléaire
que je pense qu'il faut prendre les
problèmes à l'endroit on a une société
où il faut on consomme de l'énergie il
faut décarboner cette énergie on a
aujourd'hui des centrales existantes on
ne sait pas si elles vont pouvoir être
prolongées donc quand on élabore un
programme énergétique il faut regarder
comment on décarbonne on a aujourd'hui
des solutions qui sont là c'est
développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables et c'est rénover réduire
notre consommation la question c'est si
on a la possibilité de le faire vite
aujourd'hui on a une élection rapidement
manque de résultats sur les énergies
renouvelables sur les économies
d'énergie de l'État français et masquée
par une espèce de solution magique qu'on
aurait plus d'efforts à faire et on
pourrait consommer et continuer à
fonctionner comme vous avez vu quand
même et après je fais circuler la parole
ce que nous montrait Stéphane 53% de vos
électeurs ceux qui ont voté Yannick
Jadot 53% estime que c'est une énergie
d'avenir ça vous fait réagir moi je
pense qu'il faut et je le dis d'autant
plus que je suis venu dans ma vingtaine
en France je pense qu'il faut un vrai
débat sur le nucléaire qu'on n'a jamais
eu quand on engage pour l'avenir pour
200 ans pour 300 ans quand on voit la
dangerosité des déchets du nucléaire
mais aussi la difficulté démanteler des
centrales quand on engage le pays dans
un virage comme celui-ci il y a besoin
d'un débat démocratique pour dire
comment on va faire sur notre énergie et
ce n'est pas vrai que le nucléaire va
nous préserver et va faire en sorte
qu'on avoir de l'énergie à l'avenir
parce que ça fait un point après mais
les centrales nucléaires
et parfois pas toujours en phase avec
avec une partie de vos électeurs on le
voit Pierre Cordier alors la droite
c'est très différent elle est pro
nucléaire depuis quasiment toujours dans
le droit fil de du général de Gaulle
mais alors là elle va très très loin au
Sénat parce qu'il faut expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs que le texte a déjà été
examiné au Sénat le gouvernement a
choisi le Sénat pour la première lecture
et bien les républicains ont fait sauter
l'objectif de limiter le nucléaire à 50%
du mix électrique à l'horizon 2035
Emmanuel Macron avait déjà repoussé de
10 ans cet objectif 2025 jusqu'à 2035 il
faut plus de limites au nucléaire je ne
dis pas qui qu'il faut plus de limite
simplement et vous l'avez relevé il y a
toujours eu une constance dans la droite
républicaine depuis général de Gaulle
vous l'avez dit et c'est un traversé
toutes les époques du général de Gaulle
à un Georges Pompidou à Nicolas Sarkozy
on a toujours eu beaucoup de constance
dans ce domaine là et on ne va pas
changer une vie sous prétexte que le
gouvernement dépose un texte à ce sujet
donc il a été effectivement débattu en
première lecture au Sénat nous on se
réjouit qu'effectivement il y a un texte
qui accélère le processus de création
des centrales nucléaires puisque il
s'agit de cela après quand même il faut
bien relever des terres quand même sur
le mix électrique où on en met que sur
le gaz et sur le ce que je dis c'est que
pour un équivalent de centrales
nucléaire type Fessenheim il faut
construire 4000 éoliennes d'accord donc
à un moment ou un autre il faut aussi
faire les bons choix qu'il y ait un mix
énervé énergétique pardon on y est tout
à fait favorable il s'agit pas de dire
c'est le tout nucléaire et pas du tout
l'éolien ni de solaire ni d'hydraulique
simplement il faut faire des choix
politiques et assumer cette indépendance
énergétique telle qu'elle a été voulue
il y a un certain nombre d'années pour
pouvoir avoir cette liberté et ne plus
dépendre du prix du baril de pétrole ou
du prix du gaz qui a un impact sur
l'électricité
je vous interroge dans un instant mais
je parlais de la commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée nationale tout à l'heure qui
auditionne beaucoup de personnalités et
beaucoup de membres vous en faites
partie de du gouvernement de François
Hollande on sait que la filière
nucléaire connaît des problèmes de
production on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec
toutes les centrales à la raie il y a
des problèmes de corrosion on va écouter
Arnaud Montebourg qui a été auditionné
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête vous allez vous
allez réagir et plus que l'ancien
président socialiste François Hollande
et bien finalement c'est l'accord
politique qui va passer en 2012 avec
Martine Aubry et Cécile Duplo Duflot qui
constitue pour lui l'origine du mal
écoutez l'accord était présenté par
Martin Aubry à l'époque comme un
changement de société et par ces signes
Duflot comme une rupture historique bon
pour moi c'est un accord de cuantables
c'est à dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord
sur un marqueur politique avec ma
manière à marquer les esprits et on
s'est retrouvé avec un programme qui
expliquait qu'il fallait fermer 24
réacteurs
et après
et après vogue la galère cet accord
politique c'est les fameux 50% de
nucléaire à horizon 2025 à l'époque vous
êtes d'accord avec ce qu'il dit alors
qu'on a d'ailleurs traduit dans la loi
de transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte alors qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à Arnaud Montebourg
qu'est-ce que je lui réponds pas un
petit peu la vérité quand il dit à corpe
électoral finalement il y avait un
accord électoral évidemment c'est un
accord politique mais au-delà de ça
ensuite il y a eu un programme qui a été
mis en oeuvre et on a pu parler de 24
fermetures de 24 réacteurs on s'est
pointé un objectif de réduction du
nucléaire dans la loi de transition dans
les différents débats qu'on a fixé à 50%
et l'actualité nous montre que un mix
énergétique équilibré qui n'est pas
axé uniquement sur le nucléaire ou très
majoritairement sur le nucléaire est
aussi un avantage quand on a les
épisodes de corrosion sous contrainte
qui ont frappé la filière nucléaire ces
dernières années et bien on est quand
même très heureux d'avoir d'autres
sources d'énergie lui dit que c'est
parce que on a fermé ces réacteurs que
on s'est affaiblis c'est ce qu'il dit au
fond il dit pas tout à fait ça mais
il dit qu'après François Hollande il a
essayé de faire un peu ce qu'il pouvait
en fermant Fessenheim qui a été un peu
la victime
d'élargir et de garder un peu plus de
commission d'enquête on a vraiment
l'impression qu'elle est vraiment ciblée
sur la fermeture de Fessenheim et la
cause de tous les mots qui touchent
aujourd'hui les les productions
d'énergie ce qui n'est absolument pas le
cas puisqu'il y a eu des tas de
décisions antérieures à cela je veux
parler de 2006 avec la transformation
des DF en société anonyme il y a 2008 la
décision de du ministre Borloz ou le
gouvernement Sarkozy de mettre en
concurrence les centrales
hydroélectriques maintenant tout le
monde s'insurre en disant il faut
protéger le système électrique mais
c'est quand même lui qui a donné son
accord pour l'ouverture
en 2000 avec la mission le marché de
l'électricité sur le marché européen et
puis la l'intégration la mise en
application de l'arène qui aussi assez
dévastateur et on le voit aujourd'hui
c'est le mode de calcul je vais abonder
complètement dans ce sens là et je crois
que chacun doit balayer devant sa porte
les 20 dernières années le gouvernement
Chirac enfin sush Chirac sous Sarkozy
Marie-Noëlle Baptiste elle a donné des
exemples on pourrait parler de la
faillite d'arriva qui a été dramatique
pour la filière on pourrait aussi
s'interroger pourquoi il y a pas eu de
lancement de nouveau à la construction
de centrale sous le président Sarkozy il
y a eu des erreurs faites souffrances
Hollande et il y en a probablement eu
depuis 2017 donc je crois qu'il faut
vraiment parce qu'on pas vu Macron lui
aussi sur la question des pourcentages
faut pas se tromper de combat il y a 1
pourcentage qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
60% c'est la part d'énergie qu'on
consomme qui provient du fossile et
c'est ça le combat c'est ça le problème
donc derrière se mettre des barrières
sur les énergies renouvelables sur le
nucléaire sur l'hydraulique ou tout
autre énergie des carbonées qui
permettrait de tendre vers la neutralité
carbone et complètement aberrant je
terminerai sur une chose madame Larousse
vous disiez tout à l'heure le nucléaire
ne va pas remplacer les énergies
fossiles et encore une fois là nouveau
nucléaire ne va de faire travers
d'opposer deux énergies des carbonées
entre elles moi ce que je constate je
pose rien je donne dans les pays qui ont
qui sont sortis du nucléaire est-ce que
les centrales nucléaires
a construit de nouvelles centrales à gaz
elle s'est liée de dépendance avec la
Russie grâce à North stream 1 et 9
stream 2 on en paix aujourd'hui les
lourds de conséquences ils ne sont
toujours pas sortis du charbon et on
avait on a vu d'ailleurs en Allemagne
des écologistes allez à juste titre se
battre contre des mines de charbon mine
de charbon qui sont bien là pour
compenser pourtant la fermeture de la
part du nucléaire en France la situation
énergétique est radicalement différente
et je crois que chaque pays européen qui
nous oppose c'est moins la question de
l'atome en tant que tel que du mode de
société qu'on veut promouvoir parce que
pourquoi nous on veut du nucléaire on
veut du nucléaire parce que ça nous
permet de produire de l'électricité de
façon massive et donc de garantir des
niveaux de vie de garantir une
réindustrialisation une indépendance se
passer se passer de ce mode là ça veut
dire consommer beaucoup beaucoup moins
et je crois pas aujourd'hui que les
Français le souhaitent je crois pas que
ce serait bon pour l'emploi et plus
globalement pour les entreprises on va
rentrer dans le détail concrètement
comment on va relancer le nucléaire
comme on va accélérer les choses grâce
au projet de loi voir le sujet de Tibo
inox dans un instant votre regard sur ce
débat on a on a tort d'aller chercher
des responsables c'était Fukushima donc
à posteriori c'est trop facile
que ça parce qu'en fait moi ce qui me
fascine c'est le changement de narratif
là c'est le romancier qui parle c'est à
dire que je me souviens qu'effectivement
il y a 10 ou 15 ans on nous expliquait
que c'était le diable la dangerosité de
nucléaire les déchets dans son
arriverait jamais à gérer la pérennité
etc tout ça donc on moi j'étais
terrorisé par le nucléaire Cagnac à 15
ans aujourd'hui nous explique que c'est
l'avenir la solution donc un romancier
on vous explique qu'il faut pas changer
de narratif en cours donc là il y a
quand même un faux c'est bon ceci étant
il y a quand même quelques fondamentaux
qui restent et là dans le débat sérieux
que vous avez je vais si vous permettez
mettre un tout petit peu de légèreté les
fondamentaux qui restent greativement je
vois que les discours d'un jour sont les
anti discours du lendemain bon ça ça
c'est à peu près coréen que par ailleurs
mes camarades d'écologistes que j'aime
beaucoup moi je viens de la gauche etc
mais écologiste et de gauche sont
heureusement divisés donc ça ça me fait
plaisir et que je pense que de ma vie je
ne verrai jamais des écologistes Unis je
pense que ça n'arrivera pas et que là il
y a encore un fossé visiblement entre
vous et vos électeurs ce qui est
toujours gênant et puis je de vous
suivre sur l'urgence climatique etc et
le fait que le nucléaire c'est à c'est
un moyen terme ou à long terme enfin les
analgies renouvelables aussi c'est un
moyen terme ou long terme non mais ça
fait 25 ans qu'on en parle et il y en a
pas l'éolien en mer en nous explique que
ça arrivera mais ça arrivera peut-être
dans 10 ans etc parce que je crois
qu'une station éolienne ça prend je sais
pas combien d'années 10 ans avant qu'on
a mis c'est pas du tout les mêmes
éoliennes c'est plus rapide pour les
éoliennes mais on en repars en cause du
fait qu'on a investi uniquement dans le
nucléaire et puis c'est bien ça qui a
opéré du développement des énergies
renouvelables alors on y vient on va
regarder ce qu'il y a dans ce texte de
loi et puis je vous redonne la parole
dans un tout petit instant alors
simplifier en partie les procédures pour
construire plus de pairs et surtout les
construire plus vite eDF va se lancer
dans des chantiers colossaux et très
coûteux et c'est déjà la question de
savoir qui va payer qui se pose Tibo ins
je souhaite que si le père de soi
construits si centralespr d'ici 2050 la
relance du nucléaire voulue par Emmanuel
Macron est une course de vitesse
parsemée de nombreux obstacles auxquels
la loi en examen l'Assemblée doit en
partie réponse premier défi
l'implantation pour accélérer les
procédures les EPR seront construits par
paire à proximité de centrales déjà
existantes les deux premiers seront
installés à panli en Normandie les sites
de Gravelines de Bugey et du Tricastin
sont envisagés pour les suivants pour ne
pas perdre de temps la loi prévoit de
simplifier les démarches en dispensant
notamment de permis de construire ces
nouvelles installations deuxième défi le
calendrier de construction il faut
grosso modo 15 ans pour construire un
réacteur la première coulée de béton
dans un calendrier ambitieux c'est fin
2027 pour une mise en service espérée
entre 2035
2037 EDF travaille déjà sur les plans de
ces futurs chantiers mais le précédent
de LEPR de Flamanville a montré qu'en
matière de nucléaire le calendrier de
départ est parfois loin de la réalité un
constat aussi valable pour le
financement troisième défi de ce vaste
chantier et sans doute le plus épineux
le coût de la construction des six
nouveaux EPM est estimé à 51 milliards
d'euros là encore en première hypothèse
un chantier qui donne des sueurs froides
aux nouveaux PDG d'EDF qui vient
d'hériter d'une entreprise en grande
difficulté EDF a connu en 2022 un choc
sans précédent le résultat net courant
de moins 12,7 milliards en 2022 tandis
que l'endettement augmente de 21,5
milliards pour totaliser
64,5 milliards d'euros sur ce dossier du
financement le gouvernement pour l'heure
reste vague il y a plusieurs options une
partie peut être financée par l'État
vous avez évidemment le financement au
travers des tarifs lorsque vous payez
l'électricité aujourd'hui vous payez une
marge qui permet de rembourser les
investissements qui ont été faits
l'entend mais qui néanmoins des tarifs
pour financer les futurs réacteurs
choisies une chose semble certaine la
renationalisation de DF ne réglera pas
tous les problèmes
mode Braison plus de 51 milliards
d'euros pour arriver à ses objectifs
déjà de six nouveaux EPR quand on
connaît déjà le fiasco Flamanville il a
duré beaucoup plus longtemps ce chantier
il a coûté beaucoup plus cher est-ce que
on a les moyens de cette ambition
nucléaire alors plusieurs choses déjà
c'est pas 51 milliards d'euros qu'on
décaisse sur une année c'est ce fait sur
le temps long Agnès renacher parler du
début des travaux en 2027 ce projet de
loi doit permettre de commencer la
partie or ilonucléaire en 2024 et
ensuite ça va s'étaler à minima jusqu'en
2040 donc ça se fait sur le tendon il y
a évidemment un partage du risque qui
est nécessaire entre l'entreprise l'État
et une partie qui peut être appuyée sur
l'Union européenne je rappelle que la
nucléaire est rentré dans la taxonomie
ça veut dire des financements européens
en tout cas il faut comprendre
un certain nombre énergie qui permettent
ces transitions de bénéficier de ces
facilités et puis ensuite on en fait
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en fait si on se
pose pas souvent la question pourquoi si
parce qu'à partir de 6 vous avez des
leviers sur les échelles sur l'échelle
et donc en fait vous commencez à faire
des économies le Pr on en a fait un seul
ce qui est à mon sens déjà pose des
questions parce que normalement on les
fait minima par deux et puis il va
commencer qui va démarrer seulement
maintenant après un chantier
le dernier réacteur qu'on met en service
en France c'était dans les années début
des années 2000 je croisais 2001 ou 2002
à Civaux dans la Vienne et ensuite
pendant 20 ans on a eu un seul chantier
donc c'est normal ça s'explique sur le
plan industriel qui ait eu des retards
qui les fallu réinternaliser un certain
nombre de compétences remettre la
machine en route et je crois que la
filière a appris de ces dernières années
de la construction de cette EPR du grand
carénage qui ont été des travaux
colossaux et qui continuent pour
prolonger la durée de vie des centrales
et qu'elle est beaucoup plus plus prête
à affronter ce défi avec un design qui a
été simplifié que ce qu'elle ne pouvait
être quand les travaux ont commencé donc
en tour de 2007 je crois Julie il a un
os Flamanville ça a coûté 19 milliards
les 51 milliards vous pensez qu'à la fin
la facture elle est largement dépassée
c'est au-delà la question est qui va
payer est-ce que c'est une hausse des
tarifs de l'électricité est-ce que c'est
les impôts des Français et les Français
EDF est une entreprise qui est endettée
à 65 milliards d'euros c'est à peu près
le montant de l'Argentine quand ils ont
été sortis du FMI c'est pour vous donner
quand même une ampleur des chiffres on
sait pas financer qui veut prêter de
l'argent pour construire une centrale
dont on ne sait pas si elle va réussir à
surmonter les défis technologiques on ne
sait pas si elle va fonctionner quand
elle va pouvoir produire et donc
rapporter de l'argent et donc il y a un
vrai problème pour trouver l'argent pour
pouvoir financer il y a un peu des
sentiments mais est-ce qu'on est prêt
d'un point technologique dans dans la
commission d'enquête sur l'énergie
notamment sur le nucléaire ce qui a
quand même été démontré c'est un recours
massif à la sous-traitance le fait que
l'industrie soit auto mutilé quelque
part avec EDF d'un côté Areva de l'autre
avec une catastrophe industrielle en
chêne avec des problèmes dans de
compétences sur les soudeurs etc avec et
donc on a résolu en 40 ans d'expérience
sur le nucléaire aucun des problèmes le
narratif reste le même les déchets sont
toujours aussi dangereux
du danger on voit bien que vous changez
d'arguments aussi je ne notre moins la
question
pour arriver aux 50% dans le mix
électrique c'était pourquoi on les
verres avaient mis ça c'était pour enfin
donner du développement aux énergies
renouvelables parce que si on dépend
Emmanuel Macron le disait lui en 2018 si
on dépend uniquement pour notre
électricité que du nucléaire
sauf que nos installations sont plus
vieilles et que le réchauffement est une
la compatibilité du nucléaire avec le
réchauffement climatique est une vraie
interrogation l'IRSN mène un groupe de
travail sur ce sujet oui parce que quand
il fait plus de 52 degrés dans une
centrale et ben ça pose une question de
est-ce qu'elle peut continuer à
fonctionner de manière sûre avec les et
puis aujourd'hui pour cent de l'eau la
recensement suffisante 50% de notre 26
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau par an
sont nécessaires pour refroidir le parc
actuel mais il faut de l'eau qui
restitue
et en plus folie etc sont en territoire
zones inondable je sais pas si vous avez
vu le glacier la fonte du glacier
apocalypse mais ce n'est pas de la
science-fiction c'est de la réalité
concrète aujourd'hui est-ce que demain
on veut boire de l'eau ou est-ce qu'on
va voir de l'électricité alors Pierre
Cordier faire de la politique ça fait
beaucoup de contre argument il y a des
arguments mais faire de la politique
c'est faire des choix moi je vous le dis
clairement et quand on voit finalement
mais quand on voit à quoi aboutit madame
la politique que vous préconisez avec
notamment on parle de la fermeture de
Fessenheim simplement en France on a
réouvert une centrale à charbon il y a
quelques mois pour permettre à nos
concitoyens d'avoir de l'électricité
replonger vous fermez à cause
c'était ça laissez-moi m'exprimer je
vous ai laissé parler il faut que tout
le monde puisse s'exprimer simplement la
politique que vous préconisez aboutit à
réouvrir des centrales à charbon premier
point deuxième point replonger jusqu'à
quelques mois replongez-vous il y a
quelques mois et l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens qui avaient peur concernant
la production d'énergie en France avec
des gens et d'ailleurs madame panier
renacher l'a reconnu qui ont fait
énormément d'efforts dans leur
consommation d'énergie chez eux donc à
un moment ou un autre l'indépendance
énergétique telle qu'elle a été voulue
il y a une cinquantaine ou une
soixantaine d'années il a un coût il
faudra l'assumer mais moi les gens que
je rencontrais sur le terrain étaient
très inquiets quant à cette production
d'énergie il y a encore quelques mois
moi je vais vous dire je suis président
d'une commission locale d'information
d'une centrale nucléaire dans le
département des Ardennes je vois la
manière dont les choses se passent chez
moi vous allez vous laisser penser que
finalement dans ces installations il y a
beaucoup d'insécurité que les gens ne se
sentent pas bien qu'il y a beaucoup
d'accidents qu'il y a le nucléaire qui
pèse comme ça sur les agents et sur les
habitants
on parle de la fin de l'abondance en
matière d'eau qu'est-ce que c'est
compatible cette crise climatique avec
la question pour refroidir la réponse
est oui et effectivement le placement
les placements et l'endroit où seront
installés ces nouvelles centrales
prendront en compte bien entendu cette
problématique je nous a imaginé que les
pouvoirs
iraient construire à des endroits où on
n'est pas susceptible
de là où elles sont déjà puis je vous
donne la parole juste après évidemment
des études qui sont faites pour prendre
en compte ce facteur je voudrais dire
que centrale effectivement il y a besoin
de l'eau pour refroidir les circuits
mais c'est eau elle est ensuite en
grande partie restituées à plus de 50%
en fonction que ce soit ensuite des
circuits ouverts
RTE à fait des scénarios en rapport qui
s'appelait futur énergétique dans lequel
il intégrait cette notion de
réchauffement climatique et il projetait
en 2050 fonctions de différence scénario
qu'elle pouvait être les impacts ces
impacts sont en fait extrêmement minimum
et donc il y a pas de raison de
s'inquiéter pour vous dès à présent
qu'on regarde sur les épisodes de
canicule qu'on a pu traverser c'est en
fait des réductions de production par
exemple 200 mégawatts sur un réacteur de
900 mégawatts donc on est moins d'un
quart et ça représente quelques
pourcentages par an qui sont
effectivement réduits pour préserver
l'environnement et je le précise ça n'a
pas d'impact sur la sûreté donc je dis
pas que le nucléaire est parfait c'est
pas mon point on a besoin du nucléaire
on a pas besoin des énergies
renouvelables mais encore une fois je
crois que si vous voulez être utile au
climat votre ennemi c'est le charbon
c'est le gaz c'est le fioul et c'est pas
les énergies des carbonées Marie-Noëlle
Batista je vais vous donner le mot de la
fin les socialistes je le disais sont
assez divisées et à la nuque la nupes
qui va se réunir demain je dis pardon
oui donc demain pour pour voir un petit
peu si on peut réussir à trouver une
position commune c'est possible vous
vous allez vous abstenir je crois sur ce
socialistes ne sont pas extrêmement
divisées sur ce texte la position des
socialistes sur le nucléaire est en
train de se construire dans les
différentes auditions que nous menons
dans l'objectif de la loi de
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
d'ailleurs c'est celle-ci qui aurait dû
être votée et discuter avant de
s'occuper de l'accélération des ENR et
de l'accélération du nucléaire puisque
pour nous c'est d'abord se fixer des
objectifs et ensuite se donner les
moyens de le faire ce qui est inversé
dans le calendrier aujourd'hui mais sur
ce contexte lorsqu'il est sorti puisque
nous considérions que c'était un texte
d'aménagement technique et réglementaire
et de disposition nous serions abstenus
aujourd'hui revient du Sénat avec des
éléments programmatifs qui relèvent de
la loi de programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie et qui n'a absolument rien à
faire dans ce texte ensuite la cerise
sur le gâteau ou le pompon de ce texte
il nous arrive par voie d'amendement
probablement de la part de la miss la
fusion de la scène
parce qu'il nous reste deux secondes ça
risque d'en venir un peu les débats vous
nous expliquez il y a un amendement du
Gouvernement qui rapproche l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui contrôle les
installations de l'Institut de
radioprotection chargé de l'expertise et
de la Recherche quoi on mélange le
gendarme et le en fait on fusionne
l'expertise et la décision c'est comme
si on fusionnait
l'instruction et le dans une procédure
judiciaire là-dessus votre région et
plus sur la forme sur la forme si vous
permettez une petite seconde pour
terminer sur la forme c'est pas le bon
véhicule législatif ça n'a rien à faire
dans ce texte il faut le discuter et
qu'il soit dans la loi de programmation
compris le plus nucléarisé du monde en
86 cette Tchernobyl on pouvait manger
les salades françaises et pas les
salades de l'autre côté de la frontière
pourquoi parce qu'on a dit que le nuage
s'arrêtait on a été la risée de l'Europe
en notre matière de sûreté c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis 40 ans avoir un système dual
avec la police ce qui prennent les
décisions d'un côté et l'expertise qui
fait les recherches y compris sur le
long terme c'est compris de recherche
apparemment
négociable
vous sortez complètement du champ
rationnel en agitant les salades de
Tchernobyl et en faisant c'est la
réalité de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui on a une rapidement
de vie ou de mort sur les centrales à
dire vous arrêtez vous éteignez elle a
quand même appui l'Institut de
radioprotection et nucléaire qui de
toute façon restera en appui il y a des
modèles aujourd'hui qui sont des modèles
intégrés comme aux États-Unis qui
fonctionnent très bien la sûreté a sauvé
et dangereux
alors vous avez compris c'est le débat
il arrive il arrive à l'Assemblée c'est
la Commission dans deux semaines il
arrivera dans l'hémicyclé on y reviendra
dans le détail ces techniques mais c'est
très important il s'agit de notre avenir
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau vous restez avec
moi Philippe Besson dans une dizaine de
minutes vous les voyez ils sont fin
prêts nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris on va accueillir ce soir pour la
première fois Carole Barjon de Lobbes
qui va nous parler du plein emploi c'est
l'objectif présidentiel ça peut pas être
un projet de société nous dira-t-elle le
grand reporter vincent eugieux lui aussi
interroge l'énigme Macron sur la scène
internationale et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr Marco pommier les tiktokers de
l'Assemblée mais d'abord on va parler de
vos livres Philippe Besson il y a celui
qui est aujourd'hui devenu un film je le
disais et puis qui vous a fait connaître
arrête avec tes mensonges et puis il y a
celui-ci qui a bouleversé l'équipe de
savoir regarde qui travaille avec moi
Ceci n'est pas un fait divers chez Julia
ce sont des vidéastes celle de deux
adolescents dans le père a tué la mère
regardez c'est dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduelle et puis on en parle
juste après
si on vous invite Philippe Besson c'est
parce que vous faites de vos récits
intimistes un reflet de notre société
depuis 20 ans à travers vos nombreux
romans vous ausculter nos sentiments les
vôtres aussi souvent
des liens autour de nous des sentiments
des gens et donc j'ai besoin d'aller à
l'essentiel et de trouver le mot précis
et trouver la musique qui va bien avec
avec ce que je raconte écrivain
romancier chacun de vos livres Philippe
Besson est un succès au point d'inspirer
les réalisateurs votre roman
autobiographique arrête avec tes
mensonges vient ainsi d’être adapté au
théâtre et au cinéma Andrieu
au lycée retour inattendu sur les traces
de votre amour de jeunesse
vous le connaissez bien
comme ça un amour foudroyant sur fond
d'homophobie
Guillaume de Tonquédec interprète votre
personnage
je pensais pas que mon histoire d'amour
a 17 ans avec un homosexuel au lycée
intéressant
d'électeurs déjà et c'est son plus gros
succès il s'est dit qu'est-ce que
pourquoi et en fait il dit plus j'ai été
à l'intime plus j'ai atteint l'universel
dans votre dernier roman ceci n'est pas
un fait divers une fois encore vous
explorez nos zones d'ombre celle où l'on
ne va jamais la phrase tombe comme un
coup près de la troisième page papa
vient de tuer maman les mots d'une
fillette de 13 ans à son frère de 19 ans
son mari rentre bientôt elle veut même
pas y penser quand il lui prend le bras
c'est pas pour la faire danser le
féminicide comme point de départ d'une
vie qui bascule pour ses deux enfants
qui en un instant perdent leur mère et
leur père devenus un assassin nous
autres les romanciers on peut peut-être
laisser entendre une réalité qui est une
réalité évidemment terrible une vie
prise et des vies à côté dévastées mais
aussi cette nécessité de réapprendre à
vivre et ça vous intéresse d'essayer de
comprendre comment on surmonte un
cataclysme des enfants qui devront gérer
la sidération la colère le chagrin bien
sûr la culpabilité aussi combien
d'abîmes allaient s'ouvrir sous mes
pieds mais surtout comment avais-je pu
ne m'apercevoir de rien ne rien
soupçonner vous auscultez donc ce
féminisme du point de vue des enfants
ceux qui restent et se retrouvent seuls
ceux dont on ne s'occupe que trop peu
aucune jeune fille de 13 ans aucun type
de 19 ans n'était préparé à ça aucun n'y
avait réfléchi nous apprenions en
accéléré
alors vous qui tendez un miroir à notre
société une question pour finir Philippe
Besson comment accompagner ses enfants
du féminicide pour qu'ils ne deviennent
pas à leur tour une victime ou un
meurtrier
vous l'avez la réponse j'ai une partie
de la réponse d'abord il faut les voir
il faut les entendre en fait aujourd'hui
on ne les voit pas on les entend pas
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
j'ai écrit ce livre puisque ça part du
témoignage d'un jeune homme qui me qui
me dit voilà mon père a tué ma mère mais
j'ai pas les mots pour raconter
l'histoire et toute façon cette histoire
n'intéresse personne et je me suis dit
moi le roman c'est que je suis il faut
que je lui donne une parole à ce jeune
homme et que je et je le fasse voir que
le montre et en fait la réalité elle est
là c'est que effectivement il perdent
leur mère c'est leur père est en prison
la maison dans laquelle ils ont grandi
souvent devient une scène de crime donc
les scellés sont posées et on leur dit
débrouillez-vous il y a rien de prévu
pour vous donc il y a pas d'hébergement
il y a rien du tout donc ça serait déjà
la première chose on leur dit également
donc que il y aura un procès mais que on
a tendance même si la disposition
viennent de changer un tout petit peu là
l'autorité parentale reste dévoluer au
père
sur les enfants mineurs ce qui est quand
même ça pourrait changer ça pourrait
changer mais c'était friand de savoir
que ça existe c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un
qui a tué la mère de ses enfants reste
un bon père pour ses enfants là on est
dans la folie furieuse il y a aussi
l'idée que quand les scellés sont levés
sur la maison et que les enfants
reviennent c'est à eux de nettoyer la
scène de crime c'est eux qui le font
donc les associations se battent pour
tout ça et puis il y a pas de suivi
psychologique or c'est des vies
dévastées anéanties et surtout c'est des
vies vécues sous ambivalence parce que
précisément pensez à cette jeune fille
que moi j'ai choisi de décrire dans le
roman Léa 13 ans donc d'abord elle a
assisté donc elle a une mémoire
traumatique effrayante c'est comme les
victimes d'attentat vous vous réveillez
la nuit en revoyant celui qui tire bon
et et par ailleurs 5 minutes avant que
le père ne commette l'irréparable il
était son père 5 minutes après il est
encore son père comment on fait avec ça
avec cette dualité cette ambivalence en
général ils sont engloutis dans ça donc
il faut vraiment les suivre et les
écouter celui qui raconte c'est le fils
il a 19 ans il raconte l'horreur du
crime de son père il n'a pas de nom
pourquoi parce que je voulais que il
soit tout le monde qu'il soit nous tous
il fallait il est l'empathie tout de
suite avec lui si je l'avais nommé si je
si je l'avais mis à la troisième
personne du singulier si j'avais ancré
l'histoire dans le passé lointain tout
d'un coup ça donnait des distances qui
faisaient qu'on pouvait échapper à ça je
voulais qu'on échappe pas à l'histoire
j'ai fait un livre pour que ça frappe
les esprits pour que ça éveille les
consciences ce qui est pas mon habitude
moi je suis un romancier du sensible du
sentiment etc j'aime bien ça mais là
j'étais tellement happé moi par cette
histoire vous pourriez dire comme ça je
récuse en général ce terme-là et
j'essaie de ne pas en écrire parce que
je m'en méfie terriblement mais je dois
avouer que j'espère éveiller les
conscients j'espère en tout cas qu'on va
entendre quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
entendu jusque là et que et que surtout
à côté du travail fondamental des
essayistes des journalistes des
sociologues des associations qui donnent
des informations tout d'un coup si on
passe par le registre du sensible du
narratif précisément de l'histoire qu'on
écrit de regard alors peut-être on peut
être sensibilisé bien davantage il va se
tordre dans la culpabilité c'est très
important ce sentiment de rentabilité
que vous creusez jusqu'à épuisement dans
le récit il va chercher tous les signaux
faibles qui n'a pas pu voir qui n'a pas
vu voix non c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'en fait souvent ils se sont de
coupables alors qu'on dit dans cette
histoire le coupable il est connu il est
en prison donc il est identifié et pour
autant effectivement il y a tout un tas
de questions qui arrivent qui est
pourquoi je n'ai rien vu pourquoi je
n'ai rien perçu pourquoi je n'ai rien
entendu est-ce qu'il y avait des signaux
faibles est-ce qu'il y avait des indices
même ténus
et en fait voilà il y a les
antidépresseurs de la mer il y a le fait
qu'elle porte des vêtements informe
qu'elles cesse de se maquiller qu'elle
cesse de danser alors que c'est une
femme qui aimait danser etc et lui il a
pas fait attention parce qu'il était
loin etc et c'est notre aveuglement
notre cécité qu'elle soit coupable ou
pas peu importe mais il y a l'idée qu'on
a nos vieilles on fait pas vraiment
attention à ceux qui sont les plus
proches et tout d'un coup ça nous
échappe et quand on le comprend c'est
trop tard et cette culpabilité elle elle
les ronge parce qu'effectivement si vous
aviez pu éviter ça le jeu des ETI est un
jeu éminemment cruel et si ça fera ça
renvoie d'ailleurs un livre qui a
récemment eu le prix Goncourt cette
victimes invisible à qui vous donnez la
parole elles sont de il y a Léa et il y
a ce jeune homme le narrateur son frère
on les entend pas assez on les entend
quasiment jamais c'est victime invisible
c'est pour c'est pour elle que vous avez
écrit ce livre c'est pour elle que j'ai
écrit ça parce que vraiment je me disais
on peut pas être réduit comme ça aussi
lance à l'invisibilité et en fait je
crois que j'écris souvent pour ça pour
réparer dans le sujet en évoquait à
arrêter tes mensonges et ce livre était
né aussi comme ça de un chagrin
évidemment d'apprendre que mon écriture
on écrit pour quelqu'un absolument et
d'ailleurs Guillaume de Tonquédec dans
une grande scène du film qu'il explique
et il y a cette idée de dire
je suis en colère parce que c'est des
vies passées sous les radars parce que
c'est des vies passées inaperçues parce
que c'est là et on ne fait pas attention
et moi je dis faut réparer ça donc il
faut trouver une forme de consolation et
de réparation et pour ça il faut en
passer par le roman et la justesse alors
le titre il faut dire un mot vous voulez
faire taire tous les voyeurs c'est ça
soit fait du malheur des autres parce
que aujourd'hui n'est pas un fait divers
parce que effectivement aujourd'hui
c'est juste un truc comme on s'arrête au
bord d'une route parce que on a vu du
sang une voiture un accident etc et puis
on ralentit le pas ou la course bon
c'est un peu terrible on est un peu tous
des voyeurs je me mets dedans et le
problème c'est que ça peut pas être
réduit à ça et ça n'est pas ça ça n'est
pas ça à plein de plein de dégâts alors
c'est quoi d'abord c'est un fait de
société parce que il faut tordre le coup
une fois pour toute à cette légende
absurde du crime passionnel sur lesquels
nous avons vécu dans pendant des
décennies c'est quoi le crime passionnel
c'est dire il les met tellement qu'il
l'a tué je répète la phrase tellement
elle était idiote il l'aimait tellement
qu'il l'a tué on ne tue pas par amour le
corps d'une femme n'est pas un endroit
qu'on tabasse ce qu'on violence pas du
tout
le crime passionnel aujourd'hui c'est
presque une excuse ça a été une excuse
aujourd'hui longtemps auprès des
tribunaux c'était voyez le pauvre homme
il a quand même beaucoup souffert ça
fait mémoire donc c'est presque une
circonscience c'est une autre
aujourd'hui on est sorti de ça on est
sorti et c'est surtout il faut dire que
c'est un crime de propriétaire parce que
le féminicide il intervient dans trois
cas sur 4 quand l'épouse la conjointe
dit qu'elle va partir alors
expliquez-nous parce que cette notion là
de crime de propriétaire c'est le mari
qui ne supporte pas la séparation l'idée
que sa femme va lui échapper qu'elle
aura droit à aller ailleurs qu'elle
reprend sa liberté qu'elle va
s'émanciper qu'elle cherche à
s'affranchir de lui il ne le supporte
pas il l'est en général chose fier avant
et donc il l'a tue pour la garder c'est
donc un crime de propriétaire et c'est
en cela que c'est un fait de société
parce que ça dit quelque chose d'une
société du patriarcat dans laquelle je
suis je suis un homme et cette société
m'a très bien convenu pendant des années
moi je fais pas la morale c'est une
société marquée par la domination
masculine et je suis un homme il ne m'a
pas gêné cette domination masculine
pendant des années donc c'est on vient
de là on vient de là
pour nommer ça féminicite 122
féminicides en 2021 mais je sais que
c'est pas que statistique mais il faut
le rappeler
il suffit ce mot ou pas alors il a les
mérites d'exister en fait d'exister
d'ailleurs à moitié parce que quand vous
tapez féminicide sur votre traitement de
texte il va être souligné de rouge ce
qui est intéressant parce que ça veut
dire qu'il n'appartient pas au
vocabulaire courant il n'est donc pas
dans notre monde le féminicide mais il
est un avantage c'est que il frappe les
esprits et il permet de prendre
conscience donc il est pas parfait il
faudra en trouver sans doute un autre vu
que ce récit tout ce que les mais en
tout cas ça ça existe et sans que ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'on
ne sait pas sur le père qui reste le
père malgré tout ça c'est très compliqué
parce que il faut aussi être nuancé
c'est à dire que en général le
féminicide est un point d'aboutissement
d'un continuum de violence qui a eu
avant des violences qu'elles soient
parfois physique ou psychologique et
psychologique est parfois pollu dure que
les que les physiques mais avant avant
ce continuum de violence il y a souvent
une histoire d'amour parce que pour
qu'une histoire d'amour se finisse mal
il faut qu'elle ait commencé bien et
donc cet homme vient de là d'une
histoire qui a commencé et d'un attrait
qu'il a eu pour cette jeune femme quand
il avait 20 ans et d'un couple qui la
pensée construire et d'une famille et
d'un foyer qu'il a pensé bâtir et puis
les choses sont arrivées la paranoïa la
jalousie en général le déclassement
l'insatisfaction et et la femme devient
le réceptacle de ses frustrations là et
c'est comme ça des coûts commencent la
plupart du temps et les coûts deviennent
autre chose et puis à un moment ça finit
par les réparable ce père ne doit plus
avoir l'autorité parentale sur ses
enfants mineurs il y a une loi on est à
l'Assemblée nationale ici qui a été
votée par les députés c'est une
proposition de loi socialiste il est
urgent on se dit comment c'est possible
qu'elle ne soit pas déjà appliquées
seulement le fait que ça existe c'est
formidable mais comment peut-on penser
que effectivement un homme qui a tué la
mère de ses enfants reste responsable de
ses enfants donc évidemment c'est le
simple bon sens et donc ça serait bien
que ça arrive assez vite maintenant ceci
n'est pas un fait divers chez Julia
c'est signé Philippe Besson et la
rédaction de LCP vous l'avez compris là
beaucoup apprécié vous restez avec moi
Philippe c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix
n'hésitez pas on vous attend Carole
Barjon de lobs qu'on est ravi
d'accueillir parmi notre bande de Chron
et puis le grand reporter Vincent Hugel
lui aussi
on est ravi de l'accueillir vous allez
tous les deux interroger d'une certaine
façon les ambiguïtés de notre président
à travers deux sujets très différents
mais on commence comme chaque soir par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Myriam ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'un réseau social chinois
qui devient persona non grata dans les
pays occidentaux ce réseau il s'appelle
Tik Tok plus d'un milliard
d'utilisateurs dans le monde immense
succès chez les jeunes alors pour leur
parler à ces jeunes et bien beaucoup de
politiques de députés de tous les bords
ont décidé de s'emparer du réseau l'idée
c'est de se mettre en scène dans des
vidéos humoristiques très courtes
regardez ce que ça peut donner
[Musique]
corps
au soleil
exposé allez c'est incroyable au soleil
allez sur papier ça paraît très
sympathique sauf que l'application
ou gênant
selon votre avis sauf que l'application
est bien elle a accès à vos données
personnelles historiques de conversation
liste de contacts un accès aussi à
l'appareil photo à votre micro de
téléphone alors vous allez me dire comme
tous les réseaux sociaux c'est vrai sauf
que Tik Tok est accusé et bien
d'espionner des centaines de millions
d'utilisateurs dans le monde pour le
gouvernement chinois les résultats Marco
ces derniers jours les interdictions
d'utiliser ce réseau social chinois se
multiplie dans le monde oui en plusieurs
institutions politiques ordonnent à leur
salarié de bannir TikTok de leur
téléphone c'est le cas à la Maison
Blanche dans les agences fédérales aux
États-Unis au Parlement européen au
Danemark et au Canada on a même demandé
aux députés de supprimer le réseau
social mais sans obligation alors en
France ici à l'Assemblée qu'en pense nos
députés tiktokeurs écoutez-les
face à une application opaque est-ce que
vous craignez pas pour vos données
personnelles alors nous on est assez
prudent dans notre usage c'est à dire
que moi j'utilise pas ni avec mon
téléphone ni avec mon ordinateur
personnel ou professionnel c'est mon
collaborateur qui l'utilise en utilisant
une fenêtre de navigation privée donc on
avait déjà été prudent dès le début vous
Laurent jacobelli vous si j'ai dans une
commission sensible à l'Assemblée la
commission de la défense est-ce que vous
craignez pas pour vos données
personnelles dans votre téléphone vous
savez nos données personnelles sont déjà
malheureusement quasiment public
Facebook les Américains ont accès vous
parliez de Tik Tok avec les Chinois tout
est pratiquement public parce que
effectivement la Chine est un pays qui
n'est pas démocratique avec lequel on ne
doit pas partager nos données mais vous
savez les Américains font aussi de
l'intelligence économique
des parlementaires qui s'interrogent le
président de la Commission de la Défense
thomas gassiou lui a décidé de se
retirer de l'application il y a quelques
mois et ici au Palais Bourbon la
question de l'assemblée qui se charge de
l'administration à d'y rester très
vigilante mais on se rappelle aussi on
rappelle aussi que ça fait des années
que les députés sont sensibilisés au
risque des réseaux sociaux
Marie Evenou est-ce que vous appelez les
députés à arrêter de tiktoker et donc à
désinstaller l'application pour être
proche je suis pas sûr qu'on est
beaucoup de députés qui TikTok si tenté
l'expression un petit peu quand même je
crois que c'est très marginal donc voilà
mais cela est temps pour répondre sur le
fond de la question
l'Assemblée nationale sensibilise depuis
longtemps les députés sont personnels à
l'usage
d'applications sur les réseaux sociaux
et au risque que ça comporte et on
continue à le faire on a une session
d'information qui est prévue en début
d'année 2023 pour rappeler à nouveau les
risques cyber à l'ensemble des députés
probablement qu'on va d'ici là avoir un
mail qui va qui va être adressé aux
député dans les quelques jours qui
viennent mais qui est pas lié
particulièrement à l'actualité qui est
lié au fait à de politique de vigilance
que l'on met en oeuvre depuis des années
ici voilà un panda citation pas
d'incitation donc pour les députés à
renoncer aux réseaux sociaux chinois en
revanche la France réfléchit à une
interdiction de Tik Tok sur les
téléphones de ces fonctionnaires c'est
ce qui a indiqué Olivier Véran
aujourd'hui le porte-pa du gouvernement
merci beaucoup pour cette chronique
Marco Carole d'abord bienvenue dans
cette émission vous avez choisi de vous
intéresser aux propos assumer d'une
députée Renaissance oui parce que les
écrits donc d'Astrid panosian puisqu'il
s'agit d'elle dans le Figaro la semaine
dernière ont attiré mon attention
il faut rappeler que cette député
Renaissance n'est pas n'importe qui dans
la majorité c'est une compagne de route
des tout début d'Emmanuel Macron elle
est cofondatrice de la République en
marche elle a signé les statues Amiens
en marche voilà en 2017 donc c'est une
très proche par conséquent ce qu'elle
dit est assez significatif de l'état
d'esprit d'une partie de la majorité et
sa tribune est très politique alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit elle ne ménage pas
le président de la République même si
évidemment il n'est jamais expressément
cité elle dit par exemple ouvrez les
guillemets le plein emploi ne constitue
pas un projet de société fermer les
guillemets bon ça n'a l'air de rien mais
c'est un gros missile en réalité
Macron est directement visé il faut
souvenir que pendant sa première
campagne présidentielle en 2017 le plein
emploi était vraiment l'un de ses
laitiers
et on avait bien compris en fait pour le
libéral Macron quand l'économie va tout
va bon complètement alors c'est
partiellement faux alors c'est
partiellement vrai mais c'est
partiellement faux
bien entendu que lorsque la croissance
est là que le chômage est faible les
Français sont moins stressés plus
optimistes etc mais d'une part on sait
que avec le plein emploi il y a aussi de
plus en plus de travailleurs pauvres un
vrai sujet et deuxièmement ça empêche
pas d'autres sources d'anxiété la
philosophie macronienne tant à
considérer en fait que rien d'autre
n'existe que l'économie ou presque et
pendant le premier quinquennat on s'en
souvient ça l'avait conduit à négliger
pas mal de sujets dit régalien comme
l'insécurité l'immigration
les questions même les questions
identitaires qui préoccupent un certain
nombre de Français
bref de manière plus générale à négliger
aussi l'affirmation de l'autorité de
l'État qui est un élément de stabilité
qui rassure aussi alors je vais citer un
autre extrait que vous vouliez
mentionner de cette tribune d'astrip
panosiance 6 ans après 2017 ouvrez les
guillemets il faut adapter notre ligne à
la réalité actuelle car l'hémisphère de
la compétitivité du cerveau doit parler
davantage à celui de la cohésion sociale
fermer les guillemets et bien bon je
passe sur l'ironie évidentes à propos de
l'hémisphère de la compétitivité du
cerveau qui vise évidemment la
technocratie éliséenne l'important c'est
l'expression cohésion sociale d'un mot
pour conclure il nous manque un peu de
temps ce soir Macron a fait quand même
pas mal de social non le quoi qu'il en
coûte oui dans l'épidémie mais la
cohésion sociale c'est pas seulement la
redistribution des richesses évidemment
il faut et une bonne production sociale
c'est pas là c'est pas seulement ça
c'est aussi ce qui fait tenir ensemble
une société donc des repères communs et
de ce point de vue là la montée des
communautarisme de l'individualisme
l'affirmation des identités ethniques ou
de gens le woquisme enfin bref tout ça
ça continue à brouiller y compris et
aussi j'insiste là-dessus la
dématérialisation des services de l'État
et de tous les services d'ailleurs en
général privé aussi
s'accentue la fracture numérique et donc
attention vous alertez tous les repères
et de ce point de vue là on n'a pas le
sentiment que Macron contribue à vouloir
restaurer les repères donc au contraire
et bien c'est noté merci pour ce parti
pris dans le droit fil d'Astrid panosian
le plein emploi si ça n'est que ça ça ne
marchera pas voilà pour résumer
Vincent le mystère Macron se poursuit
alors qu'il entame sa tournée en Afrique
et oui amorcer ce mercredi au Gabon la
tournée africaine d'Emmanuel Macron
illustre à merveille ce qui s'apparente
de mon point de vue en tout cas une
énigme au moins autant psychologique que
politique latitude de notre Jupiter
nationale
esprit vif et brillant adepte
revendiquer de la pensée complexe à
brouiller les messages qu'il adressent
on l'a vu au combien sur le front
ukrainien chaque clarification quant à
l'engagement résolu de la France auprès
de Kiev était suivi d'une réserve d'une
embardée rhétorique qui en altéré la
portée on a eu droit au tour à tour à
l'impératif de ne pas humilier la Russie
puis au garantie de sécurité qui commet
de fournir à Moscou et enfin quelques
heures après le discours de Munich place
à la nécessité de se garder d'écraser
l'ours russe le locataire de l'idée de
s'inscrire dans le temps long et il a
raison de le faire ils sont à
l'après-guerre était le son devoir le
hic c'est qu'avant la pré guerre il y a
la guerre et que le long terme est un
luxe très au-dessus des moyens de
l'Ukraine agressée dont la survie se
joue aujourd'hui pas après alors ça
c'est les pulsions impériales de Poutine
mais en quoi ce grief vaudrait-il pour
l'Afrique bien lundi à l'avant veille de
son décollage pour Libreville Macron a
dessiné en son palais les contours de sa
nouvelle politique africaine lui qui se
vantait 6 ans plus tôt d'avoir soldé ce
concept un constat lucide mais assez
convenu qui aurait paru novateur voire
dire ces disruptif il y a un quart de
siècle alors partenariat équilibré
respect mutuel humilité réduction de
voilure du dispositif militaire bleu
blanc rouge acte de décès de la France
Afrique si souvent intéressant fleur ni
couronne mais dont à l'évidence le
cadavre bouge encore alors soit reste
que le format même de ce périple laisse
un chouïa perplexe au nom d'une noble
cause la préservation de la forêt du
bassin du Congo il commence donc au
Gabon un pays dont le président Ali
Bongo forma l'élu à deux reprises voire
pas élus du tout brillera en août un
troisième mandat autant dire que cette
escale inaugural passe aux yeux de la
société civile locale pour un adouement
implicite et que dire le Congo
Brazzaville ou Denis assounguesso a
reconqui le pouvoir voilà un quart de
siècle lui aussi par la grâce d'un coup
d'état et de la garder au prix d'une
guerre civile rend depuis lors à la
fraude électorale et à l'embrassement de
ses rivaux donc de présidents
il y a l'Angola et le RDC la République
démocratique exacte l'Angola bon
national où il sera question
d'agriculture plutôt une bonne pioche à
cyprès que ce pays est aussi un paradis
des énergies fossiles quant à l'immense
RDC l'ancien Zaïre elle mérite bien sûr
le détour tout en surlignant les limites
du en même temps macronien le visiteur
osrottils dénoncé clairement le rôle
trouble du Rwanda par un des miliciens
du M23 qui sème la mort à l'extrême-est
du pays dans la descente aux enfers de
ce géant malade et ce risque d'enrayer
la rapprochement opéré avec Kigali et
son maître absolu Paul Kagame qui est le
vrai Macron me demande souvent mes
interlocuteurs africains celui qui a
fait le choix courageux
de regarder en face notre sanglante
histoire coloniale et post-coloniale au
Rwanda précisément au Cameroun en
Algérie et devrait à la restitution des
biens culturels pillées ou à qui à
villeprix ou celui qui au lendemain du
décès brutal du despote tchadien Idriss
Déby accourent jamais na cautionnant de
fait une succession dynastie et un
constitutionnelle soyons francs je n'ai
pas la réponse et il m'arrive de me
demander si le vrai Macron n'est pas
autant l'un que l'autre
merci Vincent vous avez passé du temps à
essayer de comprendre qui était le vrai
Macron je vous rassure mais ça reste une
énigme parce que ça livre hein
un petit peu de mal alors pour rebondir
ce que vous disiez oui on a du mal à
discerner un projet de société on entend
pas parler non plus d'éducation de santé
ou mal il y a pas de moyens pour
éducation pas assez pour la santé rien
sur la culture donc rien sur
l'émancipation d'une manière vous sentez
plus proche et encore
de lui amicalement c'est un ami mais on
peut avoir des différents graves j'ai
des différents graves j'en avais avant
ils se sont creusés parce
qu'effectivement je vois pas le projet
de société et c'est vrai que sur le plan
international on avait plutôt tendance à
se dire voilà au moins on a un mec qui
assure il sait faire etc et c'est vrai
que la dernière période parce que on
aurait pu aussi parler du Mali et de du
fait que la France est détestée
maintenant là-bas etc et bon après les
rues sont bien joué mais et donc c'est
un peu compliqué donc oui je sais pas où
il est aujourd'hui je continue d'avoir
beaucoup d'affection pour lui mais je
continue de m'interroger beaucoup et ben
voilà on vous retrouvez les
interrogations de nos chroniqueurs merci
beaucoup merci Philippe Besson merci les
affranchis Marco à très vite ceci n'est
pas un fait divers c'est-à-dire chez
Julia très belle soirée sur lcpl
commence avec ou elle démarre la soirée
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien soirée
documentaire bien sûr à demain
[Musique]